The joe rogan experience.
All he's doing is playing some really crazy game that was around before he was
ever born.
He just got into it and got really good at it.
Yeah.
The game itself,
it's bananas.
Just the stock market itself.
Just the idea that the wealth of,
of,
of a a person can vary day by day because of confidence,
you know,
confidence,
computer,
consumer confidence in a product can shift and change with Rico and then you
watching these numbers go up and down like what the fuck are you even talking
about?
Most of the explanations you see,
you know,
I watched these business sites in the market will go down and they say,
oh mark it down because of such and such in London.
And then it's like by the time that piece comes out,
that market's actually back up and they're already constructing their,
you know,
let's tie market going back up to another random feature.
You know,
it's like the,
the,
the explanations after the fact have so little to do with whatever.
Some algorithm decided it was going to suddenly ultra fast trade something and,
and throw the stock up.
You know,
it's like at this point it's,
it truly is.
That's the best place to see humans combating machines is on the marketing where
it's like there's human traders competing with these,
that programmed algorithms and the algorithms are certainly winning the war.
And if you look at their screens while they're,
while they're doing it,
it is almost like code.
Like the average person who doesn't understand it,
doesn't know what the fuck the stock market's saying,
the symbols and the essay,
Oh and this and that and the ones and the Zeros.
You look at all that,
you have no idea what that is.
I mean,
how has that really different than a computer code that you're reading me?
That's essentially like a,
a way that,
uh,
people are,
are,
are tapping into this bizarre system.
I mean,
it was at one time this sort of the price of something it had to do with some
thing,
right?
It's like there's a factory,
oh,
it's factory went slower today in the rain.
The market will go down on that.
So it was like real,
you know,
and it's gotten certainly further and further from whatever is going on in that
company or their earnings are the things,
you know,
it's,
it's absolutely abstracted to the point now where people don't even invest in
companies.
Right?
Right.
You invest in something like when Facebook went public and people bought it at
like nine in the morning,
like nine,
10 they're all pissed off,
but it hasn't gone up.
It's like,
wait a minute,
I was supposed to triple my,
well,
my wealth.
It's like,
no,
you don't.
You don't make money on the trade.
You're supposed to make money on when you've,
when you've done it.
But you know,
now we've got,
yeah.
You know,
derivatives and derivatives of derivatives and derivatives of derivatives of
derivatives on there,
which is just a way of kind of shrinking the explainer for people don't know
what that means.
So if you buy a stock,
I mean,
you know,
you buy stock in you,
I hope it goes up and then you sell it in the future.
If you'd rather make up that time right now,
I can sell it in the future right now,
right?
I can basically sell that future sale cause I think that sales is going to be a
good one now,
right?
I can say,
what if I did that trait?
I'm to,
I'm going to,
I'm going to have it now,
but
okay,
so what am I trading then I'm trading,
I'm trading on,
on an abstraction from what something's to be worse at some in the future.
So it's like I'm trading on the stock over time and then someone else will say,
well,
I'm going to trade on the abstraction of that.
I'm going to trade on whether or not people think the stock in the future is
going to be worth more next minute.
Then this minute it's like,
well what's that?
So basically what you're doing is you're buying the stock over time,
over time,
you're creating these things,
these derivatives of whatever the original investment was,
which is kind of just a derivative of the thing because the pork belly,
this driven of the pork belly,
drifters of the derivatives,
derivatives of the derivatives of the derivatives and the derivatives all goof
ball ever tighter ways of saying what is pork belly going to be worth,
you know,
on February 3rd why is that illegal?
Well,
it's legal because what it,
because the economy requires it,
right?
We have a kind of money,
That has a clock in it.
It's lent into existence and has to be paid back more than got lent out.
So our economy needs to expand by hook or by Crook.
Somehow it has to grow in order for it to survive.
That's just the way central currency works.
They need to find more surface area for the money,
more ways for people to buy stuff.
So instead of just having,
there's not enough of a company to buy.
So now we can bet on how that company is going to do in some future gut.
We can bet on that or we can bet on that.
Right.
But what we're really doing is trying to kind of compress all of this time right
onto like the head of a pin so we can bet on that.
So I don't have to sit and wait,
you know,
3000 years for Facebook to be worth something.
I can trade on his future worth now.
But the whole joke of that is people who are trading that way,
there are these computers that are trading faster than them.
So I put in one of my super fast,
crazy,
I'm derivative trade.
Goldman Sachs sees that order coming in on the computer.
They're so close to the exchange,
they can execute an order before my order even goes through based on having seen
that I was going to do what I'm going to do.
So they can literally trade in my future.
Right.
Well I am in their past.
No,
that's,
that's digital time shifting.
I mean that's,
that sounds like it's cheating.
That's like someone like running a quick server and they're local and then you
have like 150 paying.
Exactly.
That's bullshit.
I think so.
With the Solo Bullshit.
The irony of it is it's gotten so big,
right?
Derivative trading is bigger than regular trading now so that the New York Stock
Exchange actually just got bought.
The exchange itself got bought by its derivative exchange,
so it's almost just like the proof's in the pudding.
It's like the derivative owns the market at this point,
but that's when you get that.
How,
how could the government even ever deny how incompetent they are?
Then they allowed that like that alone to like someone should just like have a
broadcast on national television,
a,
you know one of those town hall sort of events where you sit down with the,
the main people that run the country and go,
how the fuck are you allowing this?
How are you,
you not fix this?
Why would you ever try to do anything else before you fix this?
When they made the decision,
they genuinely thought it would be good for business.
Let it go,
let it in the short term.
I will never understand where it all close business people promise them,
figure it out before it got really bad.
Oh my God,
we figure it out before it got really bad.
How much bigger is the derivative economy?
I don't know exactly.
I mean it seemed,
I was looking trying to find out what that,
what the sort of trading was.
It seemed from what I could tell like 94% of trades are now derivative because
they're,
because,
because there's such bigger volumes.
God that's insane.
No one's gonna like you're not going to buy,
you know,
10,000 chairs of Honeywell today cause that's,
whatever.
$60,000 or something.
But you could buy like 10,000 futures on Honeywell cause they're really cheap.
God that is so crazy.
4% of the stuff of trades are,
and how many more is,
I think it's ultra fast too is a whole other,
there's sort of two different,
two different realms.
But yeah,
it's huge.
They must all be crazy.
Everyone involved in that must know that they're bringing on the matrix.
They must know that they're there.
They're the first steps before the digital machine takes over.
They must know.
They must know that there's no humanity in that stock market shit.
That's chaos.
And,
and again,
I don't want digital technology to get blamed for this,
right?
Because the real operating system they're promoting,
it's not the digital operating system,
it's the economic operating system underneath it.
It's this 13th century central currency interest bearing debt based economy.
And none of the guys who I thought would get us out,
you know,
ev Williams with Twitter,
Mark Zuckerberg,
with Facebook,
the kids from Google,
right?
They're getting the,
each of them had a real shot.
Even Bill Gates at breaking the central economy and,
and flipping things the other way.
How do you go and do that?
Going public,
not be good,
not doing it with venture capital saying if I can,
if,
if Google can hack web search,
if Facebook can hack social,
if Twitter can hack everybody,
why can't they,
you know,
they're so busy disintermediating all these different things.
Why doesn't anyone of them yet want to disintermediate central banking and say,
no,
Mr. Chase,
we don't actually need you.
We're going to do our whole thing through Kickstarter.
Say like one of your didn't want to hear things.
Uh,
yeah,
that's an interesting point of view.
I think they probably would never want to take that stand because they would be
killed.
I would imagine there's a lot of money and uh,
and in them not being successful with that quest,
you know,
to control point at which,
you're doing paypal,
okay,
we're going to let people do individual transactions that was there,
their original model and they were going to make money on the float.
And then the banks came to them and said,
uh,
you're not allowed to do that.
You're not a bank paypal kids.
You gotta be,
you know,
can I just start as a bank or you're going to have to be connected to one of us.
And that's when,
you know,
paypal kind of becomes part of Ebay rather than whatever these crazy guys
might've done.
And I suppose there's this point,
you know,
where you know,
innocently these companies that get bigger and bigger and bigger,
hoping to do the right things,
and then it's like,
we're going to,
we're going to let you do this if you don't,
if you don't play by our rules.
But,
uh,
I also feel like there's companies that,
if you,
if you're willing to go smaller,
if you're willing to let it grow a little bit slower,
that you can scale up,
but you can become a big ethical corporation.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
okay.
You ready to record recording?
Oh,
it is already,
what the fuck's on?